President Trump is warning North Korea
that any US military action would be
devastating the president said the US
Armed Forces are totally prepared to
respond one day after North Korea
threatened to shoot down American
warplanes he also vowed to fix the mess
in North Korea and said that Kim done
own is acting very badly major Garrett
is at the White House with the latest on
this story major good morning good
morning president Trump spoke of new
economic sanctions leveled against North
Korea in the need for still more
diplomatic pressure but the president
sounded is if military action possibly
pre-emptive action is not just an option
but an increasingly viable option if we
take that option it will be devastating
I can tell you that in the Rose Garden
President Trump spoke aggressively about
potential military action against North
Korea
the North Korean government has
threatened to shoot down or aim at
American planes flying at international
airspace I'd like your reaction
devastating for North Korea that's
called the military option if we have to
take it we will American b-1 bombers
flew in international airspace but
nearer than usual to North Korea's East
Coast over the weekend US intelligence
detected signs Tuesday the north was
preparing an attempted intercept of the
next u.s. bomber flight on the east
coast in or on mig-23 jets were fitted
with external fuel tanks and an e1 the
mig-29 jets were armed with air-to-air
missiles because the North has spent so
much on its nuclear and ballistic
missile program it's Air Force is weak
its pilots poorly trained flying as
little as 10 hours a year still the
North might mount and intercept he's
acting very badly mr. Trump blamed kim
jeong-hoon for the warlike rhetoric
though his own advisers have warned
against provoking the dictator he's
saying things that should never ever be
said and we're replying to those things
but it's a reply General Joseph Dunford
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff told lawmakers there was no
evidence the North was preparing for a
conventional military strike well the
political space is clearly very charged
right now we haven't seen a change in
the posture of North Korean forces we
watched that very clear
flea on the matter of an attempted
bomber intercept the u.s. believes
there's only one North Korean pilot that
has ever flown that far out over the
ocean
even so military analysts tell us
increased tensions between the two
countries have vastly lowered u.s.
tolerance of any military engagement of
this kind thus increasing the risks of
miscalculation or conflict charlie they
do Garrett at the White House thanks
major